[Applaudissements]
alors
en février 2020 c'est-à-dire il ya un
peu plus d'un an au tout début de la
crise sanitaire des copies de 19
et bien en fait ce qui était très
important pour moi c'était que je puisse
publier mon premier livre parce que je
voulais apporter ma contribution à la
théorie psychanalytique voilà c'était ça
qui était important pour moi
ce qui veut dire que moi et ma toute
puissance
on s'est très vite heurtés à une réalité
est de taille c'est à dire le
confinement
l'arrêt des activités
on a annulé quand même trois salons du
livre
les librairies en fermer les
bibliothèques aussi donc il a bien fallu
forcément vu mon état de frustration que
je calme les ardeurs et surtout que je
lâche prise et puis franchement lâcher
prise malgré le mot bah c'est pas facile
en fait c'est pas facile du tout parce
que parce que ça demande une réflexion
ça demande une démarche
de conscience
alors dans ce cas là moi je dis toujours
lâcher prise c'est entre le contrôle et
la maîtrise et jeudi
il faut lâcher le contrôle et prendre la
maîtrise pourquoi cet important cette
notion là pourquoi c'est important de
faire la nuance entre le contrôle et la
maîtrise de la situation la maîtrise de
soi parce que ça n'a rien à voir ça n'a
rien à voir pour la bonne et simple
raison c'est que ces deux visions du
monde dans le contrôle c'est une vision
très étriqué un champ de vision
répressive pourquoi parce que c'est très
auto-centrée et donc c'est très
infantile c'est je veux je veux je veux
maintenant tout de suite
indépendamment des circonstances ce qui
est finalement la définition de la toute
puissance donc ça marche pas souvent
la maîtrise c'est différent la maîtrise
c'est une qualité qu'on peut avoir ou
qu'on peut acquérir qui est d'avoir un
champ de vision bien plus élargi en fait
c'est de la coopération c'est à dire
qu'on peut prendre en compte les
événements la nature même de ces
événements la relation aux autres ses
besoins propres le contexte est là on
coopère donc compétition dans le
contrôle
coopération dans la maîtrise et puis
finalement dans cette histoire de
bouquins
qu'est ce qui était important pour moi
c'était ma contribution la publication
oui c'est vrai on est gosse aurait pu
quand même attendre un petit peu quand
j'ai quand même réussi à le faire mais
cette contribution là m'a amené à
réfléchir et à devenir créative et c'est
ça la maîtrise de soi c'est qu'on arrive
à faire quelque chose d événements cette
pandémie j'en ai fait quelque chose et
donc pour être contributifs
accessoirement je me suis rappelé que
j'avais été journaliste dans une
première partie de carrière
et que je savais appréhender l'actualité
donc j'ai écrit des articles que j'ai
mis sur mon site internet tout
simplement et les réseaux sociaux ont
relayé et qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans
cet article de la contribution pur j'ai
aidé les gens à essayer de calmer leurs
angoisses à surmonter la situation à
structurer le temps comme on disait
souvent les psys ont été vraiment des
pigistes permanents sur les plateaux de
télé j'ai été interviewé je me rappelle
de cette journaliste qui m'avait demandé
décrypter pourquoi
elle rencontrait dans ses enquêtes des
couples qui soit voulait absolument à ce
moment là faire un enfant dans le
confinement peut-être pour conjurer un
chaos sociétal soit au contraire décidé
de bannir l'idée d'une procréation parce
qu'il était hors de question de rajouter
un petit être humain dans ce monde
pourri
je lui dis que c'est la même chose en
fait c'est exactement de la même chose
parce que quand tout nous échappe c'est
normal de vouloir reprendre le contrôle
de la situation et est forcément de
décider quelque chose
et je crois en plus fondamentalement que
décidée s'est cherché à aller mieux
en tout cas moi décidé
je les fais un jour j'ai décidé d'entrer
comme on dit en psychanalyse j'avais une
vingtaine d'années parce que moi et mon
surmoi
sur moi c'est la toute puissance vous
savez c'est cette instance du contrôle
dans la dans l'inconscient et bien en
fait on était très très hypercontrôle
ans on avait vraiment besoin de faire
tout par nous mêmes moi et mon surmoi on
ne faisait pas confiance vraiment à
grand monde et surtout
dans mon immense vite eu d'enfant unique
je n'avais pas beaucoup de piliers sur
lesquels me reposer et cette hyper
contrôle était quand même très gênant
dans mon quotidien c'était génial dans
mes relations d'un évidemment donc j'ai
voulu y voir de plus près et puis je
savais au fur et à mesure de cette
psychanalyse que dans le fond je le
tenais de ma mère ma mère qui était très
hyper contrôlante elle était tellement
hyper contrôlante que en fait voilà ce
qui se passait dans la maison c'est à
dire qu'elle était très intrusive très
invasive elle avait besoin comme ça que
rien ne lui échappe et donc
régulièrement elle attendait que je
parte à l'école donc au collège puis au
lycée ce qui veut dire que ça a duré
quand même des années et elle opérait
des fouilles dans ma dans ma chambre
dont qu'elle empiétait mon périmètre il
faut imaginer des fouilles un peu comme
les stellistes d'un pénitencier
il faut imaginer les fouilles comme les
cellules d'un pénitencier c'est vraiment
elle cherchait quand je rentrais de
l'école il y avait forcément un butin
c'était pas le grand banditisme
c'était un journal intime c'était des
paquets de bonbons des petits mots doux
quand j'en recevais ça n'est pas non
plus de quoi fouetter un chat mais ce
qui était intéressant c'est cette hyper
contrôles là qu'il fallait trouver un
butin le poser sur mon bureau et justes
ne rien dire
quand je rentrais de l'école je montais
dans ma chambre je voyais je savais
qu'elles savaient que nous savions
et là on a atteint des sommets d'hyper
contrôle
ce que rien n'était dit moi je fais
niais d'être impassible alors que je
fulminais de rage d'avoir été évidemment
non respectée dans mon périmètre et elle
elle avait l'air très très contrarié ça
tenait finalement au frottement de ses
sourcils et à son mutisme ça a été
vraiment décider des moments d'une
culpabilité assez rare et et franchement
qu'un parent produit ça à son enfant
c'est ça qui m'a questionné ce qui m'a
d'autant plus questionné sait que sa
mère était une championne olympique de
l'hyper contrôle et alors là vraiment
mauvaise pioche c'est bien ma grand mère
maternelle qui m'a élevé quand j'étais
tout petit hélas le d'hyper contrôle
aller à un tel niveau c'est que je me
rappelle encore j'avais j'ai tout petit
puisque j'étais dans la cuisine sur la
propreté c'est vous dire et elle me
levais elle me mettait sur le pot elle
me disait fais comme si en fait elles
étaient censés croire qu'elle avait un
pouvoir en fait sur mon organisme c'est
vous dire à quel point certaines mères
peuvent aller dans l'abus
[Musique]
et donc vous voyez bien que dans le
cours de ma thérapie j'avais la halle se
dessiner un arbre généalogique avec une
branche maternelle dans un matriarcat
absolue et ça m'a littéralement horrifié
par ce que j'étais à la croisée des
chemins
moi fille et petite-fille d'hyper
contrôlante et que si je ne mets pas je
ne mettait pas un terme à cette
reproduction forcément j'allais faire
souffrir mes deux filles qui allait
peut-être elle aussi reprendront mais ça
allait s'arrêter quand
donc il fallait le réformer et c'est
vrai que cette question de la
reproduction m'a toujours beaucoup
beaucoup intrigué à vouloir produire
quelque chose dont on a souffert mais le
reproduire quand même
alors
c'est là où il faut comprendre c'est que
ces mères c'est un cauchemar
le portrait que j'en fais là vous pouvez
peut-être le reconnaître dans votre
entourage on peut être vous même si on
pourra en parler peut-être après si vous
voulez mais
vous savez comment on les appelle en
fait c'est mr hyper contrôlante dans mon
cabinet on les appelle les rênes de la
ruche
parce que tout tourne autour d'elle
elles sont très intrusive elle sont
invasive elles ont besoin d'être
consultée pour tout et rien elles ont
besoin de l'ordre d'organiser elle-même
le noël parce que chez elle c'est mieux
elles ont besoin de tout contrôler et
rien n'est possible autrement en
revanche c'est vrai qu'elles sont quand
même exceptionnel d'abord maintenant
elle travaille et en plus de leur
activité professionnelle
elles sont partout c'est à dire que elle
considère qu'il faut produire les choses
comme elles le veulent elles par leur
prisme donc élevé ici tout est cette
hyper contrôle a fait quand même
qu'elles sont très fiables à 100 mille
pour cent c'est à dire qu'elles vont
pour t'occuper bain des repas des
courses des sorties d'école
des devoirs évidemment elles sont
capables de cuisiner en faisant réciter
une poésie tout en regardant dans le
jardin ce qui se passe elles sont
vraiment extraordinairement
mobile et surtout
elle s'occupe de l'administration de
l'administratif du ménage de
l'organisation des vacances elles elles
sont des mamans taxi elle accompagne eux
l'un au foot l'autre à la danse elles
sont toujours à l'heure jamais en retard
elle rate jamais un rappel de vaccin
elle encourageait les éduquer la
compagne elle se déguise dans les
kermesses elles font des repas
d'anniversaire extraordinaire dégoûté
et tout ça en fait ce n'est pas
extraordinaire parce que c'est au pas de
charge
c'est lourd c'est pesant et surtout ça
manque cruellement d'un élément d'un
élément c'est l'affect ce sont des mères
que l'on hamel que l'on appelle des mers
opératoire c'est à dire qu'en fait on
les définit dans une fosse présence
elles sont là tout le temps et pourtant
pourtant il manque l'élément essentiel
qui l'affectif
alors eh oui elle ne parle que par
injonction donc elle donne des ordres
ce qui fait qu'elles sont vraiment des
reines pour le coup dans un absolutisme
prennent vraiment primaire alors comment
c'est possible
comment c'est possible d'en arriver là
alors on est tout amour quand un enfant
n'est qu' on est tout émerveillé qu'il
est vraiment fantastique et pourquoi on
devient ce gendarme d'ailleurs dans ma
patientèle il ya bien quelqu'un qui
l'appelle mon général et bien en fait
elles ont peur
elles ont peur et c'est ça qui est
tragique c'est parce que dans le fond
elles savent pas ce qu'on va dire
d'elles elles sont là pour parer à tout
elle espère éventuellement qu' il n'y
aura pas d'accident qu'on pourrait venir
leur reprocher elles ont un énorme
besoin de reconnaissance aujourd'hui à
brandir une espèce de charge mentale
qu'elle cultive elle même et quand même
temps elle reproche aux autres or pour
autant c'est bien elle qui
déresponsabilise c'est elle qui ne re
qui ne peuvent pas en fait délégué quoi
que ce soit et donc elle manque
d'empathie forcément parce que elles ne
comprennent pas ce que l'entourage
ressent pour vous voyez c'est finalement
très infantile c'est d'autant plus un
sens il que l'air de rien si vous
regardez bien ce sont des mères qui
boudent vous rendez compte que la
bouderie c'est quand même le matériau de
de l'enfant par définition est elle
goûte pas deux heures ce sont des femmes
qui sont capables mais j'ai des
témoignages des récits incroyables dans
ma patientèle ce sont des femmes qui
sont capables de bouder plusieurs jours
voire des semaines donc en fait elles
chargeant culpabilité l'autre pour
pouvoir continuer à prédominer
et puis en fait comme elle ne négocie
rien on peut aussi imaginer qu'elle ya
comme une espèce de rivalité qui
s'instaure et il est très courant de
constater que dans le fond elles sont en
rivalité avec leurs propres enfants qui
sont gâtées par leur grand-mère donc
leur mère à elle et elle voit bien que
leurs enfants ont un traitement bien
supérieur est bien plus amicale
affectueux qu'elles n'ont eu de leur
propre mère et c'est un litige qui va
rester de manière très inconsciente
enfants en toile de fond en quelque
sorte donc oui c'est mr opératoire dans
une fosse présence ont un hyper contrôle
qui est d'abord la peur de ne pas être
validé d'abord de ne sommes pas se
sentir forcément à la hauteur de l'enjeu
parentale et puis surtout on peut parler
d'un ce qu'on appelle un complexe de
castration c'est à dire cette idée qui
est un préjudice à réparer de l'enfance
peut être parce que dans le fond elle
n'aurait pas reçu de regard qu'elle
aurait été en droit d'attendre
si peut-être elle avait été un garçon il
ne croyait pas que c'est de l'ancien
siècle c'est encore une réalité que où
on investisse davantage un garçon qu'une
fille en tout cas c'est mr hyper
contrôlante on peut considérer que c'est
un dénominateur commun chez elle
puis vous voyez dans ce très beau dessin
qui a été fait par sylvie faure qui est
une illustratrice remarquable tous ces
bruits sein ne sont- elles vous voyez ce
côté un peu masculin elle part en
conquête parce que dans le fond dans son
histoire il ya une revanche à prendre et
elle doit dépasser les limites du
supportable pour pouvoir se ressentir
donc voyez ça colle pas du tout du tout
avec l'image d'une femme accomplie dans
la pleine fleur de l'âge et mentenon
elle gouverne elle gouverne le problème
dans cette gouvernance là c'est qu'elles
sont des régente absolutiste sans
contre-pouvoir ya personne qui vient
s'opposer à ça c'est à dire les
compagnons de vie qu'elles se sont
choisis sont soit des gens qui sont
vraiment ailleurs serre qu'ils sont
absents ils ont beaucoup investi le
champ de leurs activités
professionnelles et de ce fait là et
bien ma foi ils ne sont pas là pour voir
ce qui se passe de manière intrusive
dans la maison
soit ils sont d'une complaisance
incroyable ils sont gentils et man
vraiment attendri par ces femmes et je
pense que là ya aussi ce dénominateur
commun de l'infantile parce que ce sont
des hommes qui ont besoin de s'abriter
quelques parts sous cette férule et ça
leur va bien et puis à ceux qui
subissent qui subissent comme les
enfants alors gardons le plus dur dans
ce surinvestissement c'est que le bilan
n'est pas très bon on peut dire que même
c'est une action contre productif parce
que les enfants ci peut arriver qu'il
soit à moi plutôt très résistant mais à
ce moment le problème c'est qu'ils vont
vers des transgressions des cachotteries
ils font leur bulle alors c'est
peut-être pas très grave quand c'est pas
dangereux mais j'ai évidemment moi j'en
accompagnent certains qui sont allés
jusqu'à la toxicomanie et de manière
très très très très violente pour eux
mêmes je pourrais même dire que
l'anorexie quelque part c'est une forme
de contre-pouvoir à un hyper contrôle
maternelle à moment la jeune fille dit
stop je prend le contrôle de mon corps
et tant pis si ça ne te plaît pas c'est
ce qu'on appelle de la résistance
passive est dû de ce fait là les mères
et pères contrôlante n'ont plus aucun
accès elle s'arrache véritablement les
cheveux et ça devient une tension
nucléaire dans la maison
où alors ou alors ce sont des enfants
qui s'étaient littéralement ils
s'éteignent peuvent s'auto sa beauté il
manque d'estimé d'eux mêmes ils n'ont
pas confiance il sa next et
émotionnellement aussi ils sont dans ce
qu'on appelle la crainte de
l'effondrement celles qui vont éviter de
faire quelque chose parce que de ce fait
la malle ça va permettre de se prémunir
d'une espèce de
d'énervement d'éclatement ou de quelque
chose que une liste dont il serait
gestionnaire et qu'il pourrait pas
supporter eux mêmes par culpabilité
alors moi j'ai inventé un concept pour
expliquer certaines choses à mes
patients et je ce concept je l'appelle
le concept de la poupée préférée
c'est une poupée vivante
c'est une poupée qui se laisse animé par
une mère hyper contrôlante et qui ne
s'appartient pas donc on peut faire
faire ce qu'on veut et ça arrive
beaucoup
globalement je pourrais dire que 100 %
des jeunes qui viennent à mon cabinet
sont des jeunes qui sont des poupées
préférées ce sont des enfants
consolateur parfois ils sont treize ils
sont très infantile ise
parce que la maman a besoin de se
consoler l attention c'est pas le
contraire bien sûr mais alors elle est
coiffée les habiller les gronde elle les
exhibe quand ils sont plutôt dans des
bonnes performances scolaires où on fait
quelque chose de chouette à l'école ou
en sport ou je ne sais quoi il ne
s'appartiennent pas et il ya évidemment
des mères qui persiste à vouloir un
senti lisez leurs enfants au moins un ou
deux s'il ya la frapna frais très
nombreuses parts pour pouvoir justement
se rendre utile puisque leurs prises
c'est justement l'utilité elles ont
besoin de tout contrôler parce qu'elles
ne peuvent se reconnaître que en tant
que personne utile
alors ça me rappelle une patiente et si
l'exemple que je vous proposerai
aujourd'hui elle arrive à la 50 ans elle
dit qu'elle va bien ok j'écoute séance
préliminaire elle me parle de son fils
qui est son troisième 6 qui est un jeune
adulte il vient d'avoir la majorité et
il ne fait plus rien il est dans sa
chambre il et renonce à ses études
supérieures et d'ailleurs elle sait même
pas ce qui se passe dans la chambre
parce que à ce stade là il lui a
interdit l'accès mais il ne s'oriente
plus il ne peut rien faire pourquoi
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
qu' il a tellement été habitué à obéir
au doigt et à l'oeil avec le sourire à
cette mère hyper contrôlante que dans le
fond il a littéralement aboli sa pensée
donc à un moment ils doivent s'orienter
à un moment il doit s'organiser dans sa
projection de lui-même et saint carné il
en est littéralement incapables et je
sais pas si vous imaginez le truc quand
même c'est que cette femme vient me voir
moi
pour parler de lui
mais sans lui vous voyez à quel poids
elle a dirigé les débats et il n'a pas
le droit de cité donc vous voyez que à
un moment moi je me dis c'est incroyable
donc je lui dis madame peut-être on
pourrait parler de 2,2 ce qui a produit
son attitude
et c'est là qu'elle commence tout de
suite à élargir le champ de vision à
coopérer avec moi et c'est là où je me
sens contributive et elle me elle
m'explique qu'elle a une mère
hypercontrôle entretien dont on été
faites pour se rencontrer
et que la froideur maternelle n'a
encouragé à être dans cette hyper
contrôle et qu'elle n'a pas vu venir le
péril gym et je crois madame que c'est
vous que peut-être je pourrais recevoir
en thérapie et non votre fils parce que
votre fils futur qui les ratent très
bien et elle est restée et je la
remercie et j'espère vraiment pouvoir
être aussi contributive qu'avec cet
exemple là parce que depuis qu'elle a pu
verbaliser parce que l'acte de
verbalisation c'est le champ de la
psychanalyse qui le propose c'est cette
capacité qu'on a identifié ce qui ne va
pas pour le rendre moins flou et de fait
ça c'est sûr qu'elle parle maintenant
elle parle dans mary binaire elle parle
à parler à son fils elle a parlé bien
sûr à son mari qui lui était complaisant
elle a parlé à saison fossé autres
enfants elle a parlé à sa mère et elle a
compris elle a élargi son champ de
vision est allé passer vraiment du
modèle de contrôle au modèle de maîtrise
et elle a compris qu'elle avait
reproduit quelque chose d'une grande
souffrance et donc c'est là où cette
étude que j'ai menée pendant trois ans
dans mon cabinet alors en toute humilité
sur des dizaines et des dizaines et des
dizaines de patients jeu j'ai bâti une
théorie qui s'appelle la la trilogie
inconsciente que vous voyez là sur ce
dessin
qui est le fait que dans le fond il ya
sept enfants cette poupée préférée en
nous
ce maintien si on n'y comprend rien et
qui colore nos comportements qui colore
cet aspect absolument délétère de nos
relations et en quoi tient cette
trilogie inconsciente en trois piliers
je souffre et si je souffre comment
faire pour arrêter d'en souffrir et ben
normaliser ce qui se passe autour de moi
ainsi je ne souffre plus ça s'appelle un
mécanisme de décence le problème de la
normalisation c'est qu'une fois qu'on
est dans ce piège là forcément on
reproduit puisque c'est normal alors ça
donne des choses dingues parce que la
reproduction j'en ai déterminé trois
types le premier type par exemple c'est
reproduire les choses sur soi
par exemple ça pourrait être j'ai été un
enfant dévaloriser toute ma vie
et bien voilà je continue à me
dévaloriser avait humilié parce que dans
le fond ça fait partie des choses que
j'ai compris de moi et je n'ai le droit
à rien d'autre ça c'est un principe
masochistes ça peut être aussi une
reproduction sur autrui par exemple ça
c'est fascinant des gens qui font vivre
des calvaires à rester cinq heures
durant sur une table de travail un
dimanche en plein alors qu'il fait beau
en plein été à cause d'un devoir de
maths que l'enfant ne fait pas alors que
eux mêmes ont vécu ce calvaire avec
l'injonction à la réussite scolaire 30
en avant avec leurs parents ça s'appelle
du sadisme
donc c'est une reproduction sur autrui
et la souffrance que l'on reproduit sur
les deux sur soi et sur autrui et bien
le l'hyper contrôle en fait partie parce
que dans le fond pour être hyper
contrôlant il faut drôlement accepté de
faire du tort à l'autre et je voudrais
un jour que les enfants cessent de venir
me dire si si j'ai été un enfant très
heureux parce qu'on voit bien que la
normalisation s'est posée là et je
voudrais bien qu'on comprenne que cette
hyper contrôle sur l'autre en fait c'est
une énorme exigence une énorme vigilance
sur soi pour soi contre soi même et
c'est pas supportable alors cette
trilogie inconsciente qui est donc
devenu le sujet de ce livre qui en fait
effectivement a fini par être publié eh
bien j'aimerais alors c'est pas une
trouvaille et non plus dans dans la dans
la bibliothèque psychanalytique il ya
des tas de concepts qui explique la
reproduction les erreurs répétitive mais
je trouve que c'est une façon assez
simple et assez xai accessible de
l'expliquer et ça fait partie de mon
credo pour arriver à cette maîtrise de
mon art qui est d'être psychanalyste
enfin j'espère et bien j'essaye de
simplifier les choses de les rendre très
très accessible et démocratise à bhl
pour pouvoir les rendre utiles alors
donc si ce soir j'ai
j'espère en tout cas avoir convaincu
quelqu'un au moins une personne si parmi
vous quelqu'un a compris que dans le
fond coopérer avec les événements être
contributifs par rapport à l'autre dans
la relation à l'autre par rapport à soi
et à son droit au bonheur
j'aurais apporté ma contribution
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]